let's think a little bit about why
credit default swaps are famously
referred to by warren buffett as
financial
weapons of mass destruction
weapons of mass destruction at the
center of it and there's not just one
credit default swap writer but i'll put
one in the middle because each of them
are writing many many credit default
swaps aig is the most famous but you
have some writer here they're given some
good credit rating maybe in the past
that credit rating was actually earned
by a credit rating agency
and then frankly the credit rating
agency got a little sloppy and really
didn't wasn't willing to downgrade them
given all of the credit default swaps
all the obligations they're taking on
credit rating agency and as you could
tell i kind of view these guys and these
guys are the as the main culprits and
maybe a little bit of the regulatory
agency saying hey look these guys are
writing insurance maybe we should
actually regulate them but with that
said you have companies over here i'll
do the companies in this pink color
and they want to borrow money from other
parties let's say investors i'll do the
investors in this orange company in this
orange color so the investors are
lending the money the companies give
them interest so investors lending money
giving interest lending money giving
interest lending money giving interest
and then these investors it seems pretty
reasonable say hey look there's a guy
over here with a double a rating the
people that we're lending to don't have
a double a rating this guy has a b maybe
this guy has a double b
maybe this guy only has a single a and
so he says look i want to be completely
safe here so i'm going to pay a little
bit of a premium to aig
or to the writer whoever the writer is
and in exchange i will get insurance
i will get insurance on
on this debt i will
i will get insurance
in
insurance and it seems pretty reasonable
except for the fact that this player
right over here did not put out any
money aside or did not put the
appropriate amount of money aside to
properly take to properly account for
all of these liabilities all of this
risk that is taking on and also all of
these risks are correlated you can
imagine a situation where the economy
goes bad now all of a sudden
not now all of a sudden this company
defaults on its debt and this company
defaults in debt in fact when the
economy is good it's likely that very
few of these companies are going to
default and when the economy goes bad
it's likely that many of them will
default but the real problem is is as
soon as these defaults start happening
then the credit default swap writer is
going to have to actually start paying
for the defaults they'll get the bad
debt and in exchange they'll make the
other side of the credit default swap
that the holder of it they will pay to
make them whole and so this could take
them out of business and all of a sudden
the people over here who are who thought
that they had insurance no longer do and
they might actually say wait i can only
hold double a debt and they might
actually have to dump this debt onto the
market even worse you have all of the
people who
all of the people over here who didn't
lend any money to anybody but they
really just wanted to make side bets
either the side bets might have been
pure directional bets on the state of
the economy saying hey i think a bunch
of companies or i think this company in
particular is going to default on its
debt and they too could get credit
default swaps really as just side bets
so just for maybe maybe this right here
is one billion dollars in debt maybe
these all of these parties took side
bets on this guy so even though there's
only a billion dollars of debt here
there might be four or five or ten
billion dollars worth of insurance on
that one billion dollar bet
so if all of a sudden this one company
can't pay it's one billion dollars now
aig is on the line not for one billion
but for four or five or six billion
however much it insured it for so it
allows people to insure for things that
they don't have the other the the
offsetting liability for and so you can
imagine these guys some of these people
if this guy fails will just kind of take
a loss and and that's bad in all of the
rest because they were expecting that
they wouldn't but some of these players
might have had offsetting hedges they
the only reason why they might have felt
comfortable taking on some other
liability is they said look if the
economy gets goes really bad i have i
have this insurance over here and they
did that transaction with another third
party now all of a sudden if if the
economy goes bad and these guys say hey
look i'm in a lot of trouble good thing
i have this credit default swap but then
it turns out that they don't because the
counterparty here fails the credit
default swap writer now all of a sudden
this guy becomes insolvent but this guy
was was dependent on this guy paying and
he thought he was good because he even
looked at this guy's books and said this
guy had offsetting hedges and now this
guy might fail and so you could have
this entire cascade through the entire
financial system